I've been something of a busy boy so
it's been a little while since I've done
a book video and I know some of you
really liked him I know some of you
really don't but if that's you then you
probably didn't click this video so
that's fine you might remember that a
couple of months ago I did a video in
spring talking about what I read over
the winter so this is my summer video
talking about what I read over the
spring I'm a seasoned pro at this I'll
leave links to the Amazon pages for all
the books about to talk about are down
there in the description do support your
local book shops where you can guys
because I love a good book shop but I
realized that sometimes this is the only
way to get some of these books and I'm
recommending quite a few this video so
maybe you want to pick some up the first
book that I'm gonna talk about is
probably the most evil book I've ever
read and that's the prince by niccolò
machiavelli so this is a rather slender
book but a very famous one it is also
several hundred years old rumors
originally published its first published
in Italian in 1531 and even if you
haven't heard the book you've almost
certainly heard of the name Machiavelli
from the adjective Machiavellian the
book is part of a genre called mirrors
to princes which is a class of books
that was given to Prince's young men in
Italy where the book was written to
guide them about how to be a ruler how
to rule their lands how to conquer new
lands how to conduct themselves and the
prince is definitely the most famous one
now this genre of books may sound boring
to you you are almost certainly not a
16th century Italian prince ready to
take over a principality but this tiny
little book has been used as a pamphlets
as a blueprint for tyranny since its you
know publication it Stalin for example
had a annotated copy of the prince and
he had it because the advice given in
this book isn't specific to the time or
the technology of the era although some
of it is for some reason Machiavelli
really hates mercenaries but the book
asks and answers questions like is it
better to be feared or to be loved is it
ever justifiable to use evil acts in you
know making a better world of making a
better world for yourself specifically
and it's a very uncomfortable read for
example here's a quote we can say that
cruelty is used well when it is employed
once for all and one safety depends on
it and then it is not persisted in but
as far as possible turned to the good of
subjects this is the book that tells you
it is better to be feared rather than to
be loved
it is the book that tells you that real
truths realpolitik is far more important
than any ideals you may have and it may
be very uncomfortable to read it because
it is a very persuasive argument you
know it's persisted this long it's been
used by so many people because it's very
persuasive and you kind of ask yourself
when you read this book why aren't I
doing these things why am i trying to be
a nice guy and ultimately I think it
comes down to the fact that I hold
ideals as being more important than
Machiavelli did and the people who
followed in his footsteps he followed
his advice like Stalin did so much as I
had a really interesting time reading
this book and also very interesting time
listening to and in our time I'll cast a
radio episode which is available on the
BBC for a lot more analysis about it I
don't know if I could not wholeheartedly
recommend it because this is a five-star
book but I think it is a book that
encourages evil and a book that itself
feels malignant once it gets parts the
sort of stages of you know this is what
the Pope did that by the way is the
structure of the book it's like it would
make a point and then who Machiavelli
will back it up with a classic example
from Rome or Greece and then a
contemporary example from Italy or
France or whatever and a lot of that in
the beginning is when you conquer new
territory should you live there that
kind of thing once it gets past that it
does get into this nefarious quality and
I don't know I think I trust people
enough to read this book incidentally if
you'd like to see my full reviews of
these books they'll be a link down there
in the description to my Goodreads where
I am actually kind of active at the
moment I've been quite a busy boy with
books and I write a review for
everything I read you can follow me
friend me whatever I still don't
completely understand how Goodreads
works after the prints I went on to read
Artemis by Andy weir which I don't have
with me I left at my parents house so
you can have two oh look there it is so
I'm one of these people that absolutely
loved the book of the Martian and the
film film is solid but the book of the
xkcd comic about it where it's just that
scene from Apollo 13 where they make a
square peg fit into a round hole for how
many hundred pages it's so accurate and
god damn it I love it
the Martian was a very stripped-down
sci-fi story well not even sci-fi really
was only just in the future on Mars and
it really it was about science it was
back engineering Artemis is about
economics it's a book about the first
colony on the moon which has it's sort
of economic model taken from the luxury
resorts from places on earth in places
like the Maldives for example where you
make an ultra rich people going there
and the local people kind of thrive over
that industry but they themselves a much
poorer and there's a big stratification
of sort of people in the resorts or in
the colony and I went to an event where
I met Andy weir and I've gotten to sign
my copy of the book and shook his hand
and everything and he basically admitted
that this book was effectively an excuse
writing this book was an excuse to
explore the economics of a lunar colony
and if you're interested in economics
and maybe after watching some of my
recent videos you now ah I imagine this
book will be much more interesting to
you than it was to me when I read it I
personally don't find sort of
macroeconomics as interesting as science
you know I have two science degrees so
what you expect but that wasn't my
biggest problem with the book my biggest
problem with the book was the fact that
the Martian worked because it was
effectively one dude monologuing and
then there are other people on earth
trying to help them there are people on
a ship trying to help him it wasn't so
much about the human to human
interaction it was more about the
science and about a very geeky guy
somewhat like Andy weir monologuing
Artemus by contrast is about jazz
Beshara who isn't anything like Andy
weir she's female teenager and Muslim
and also incredibly unlikable one of the
least likeable protagonists I've ever
seen in a book it's about her and her
getting caught up in this plot which I
won't spoil obviously but it's to do
with economics and it's to do with a
whole bunch of people interacting with
each other and that was kind of a
problem because I don't think anywhere
can write that very well that said I did
still enjoy the book I definitely you
know sped through it much like the
Martian I devoured this book it was you
know page-turner
it just it was little it was great in
concept but not so great in execution in
short enjoyable not as good as the
Martian but still probably recommend
especially if you're into economics
next up something completely different a
history of the world in 12 maps by Jerry
Broughton this is a rather chunky book
with really quite small type this was
quite a work to get through and it took
me a long time to read it not least
because I'll be honest it wasn't very
interesting to begin with to zoom out
though before talking about that this
book is what it says on the tin it takes
us from Babylonia and the very first
civilizations to the very present-day
through the technology that we used to
visualize the world and of course that's
maps but that doesn't just mean paper
maps and the last chapter it's actually
the first I think ever history of Google
Earth and sort of geospatial
applications digital geospatial
applications it's a great way of doing
the world history because you know one
way of doing world history is the
temporal aspect of it right it's the way
in which we view the past that's what
the study of history basically is
geography by contrast is a spatial field
it's their spatial relations between
different things and then you can also
pile in other things into that different
chapters of this book basically use the
special relationship between information
and the way that we portray it but then
also ties in religion it ties in
geopolitics it ties in even
multiculturalism and I think it was 11th
century Sicily this but really is a very
broad brush very very good history of of
the world I think if you were to give an
alien this book as their first ever
primer to earth they wouldn't really
understand world history but if you are
kind of aware this provides a kind of um
a series of magnified looks at different
sections of the world so for example one
chapter talks about the horrific mappa
Mundi which is a Christian map of the
world and ties in a whole bunch in how
Christians saw the world in the medieval
period and how the map was actually sort
of the theological construct just as
much as a spatial one there's another
chapter about Empire which is set in
Korea and China and looking at Korean
and Chinese maps of the world and how
those two nations related to each other
in the concept of Empire and then
there's another chapter on the map of
France made by the cassini family which
was the first one to be done using
trigonometric techniques and kind of
represented the
scientific revolution arriving in
mapmaking and you know from that point
on everything was done differently so
it's not trying to be a comprehensive
history of the world it's looking at key
places and key events and delving really
quite deep very well researched into
those areas
unfortunately the beginning was a slog
the beginning as you kind of would
expect really talked about Greek map
making and talking about different
projections of maps and you know getting
this idea across that you can't ever
represent a spherical object this the
surface of a sphere on a flat surface
without distortion it's just impossible
and you know talking about Greek efforts
on that and it just dragged it was only
way to go into the second chapter
talking about exchange between different
cultures and between the Arab world and
Christian world the things start to pick
up and then when it broke away from
Europe and start talking about career in
China suddenly I was like yes this is
fantastic really really like this book a
solid recommendation if you're
interested in world history in a
multiculturalism kind of generally
looking at different areas of the world
history it isn't completely Eurocentric
although there is you know definitely a
lot of emphasis put on Europe but just
just real good
interesting book next another book which
I don't have with me but is it my
parents house the good immigrant by
Nikesh Shukla a massive shout out has to
go here to my mate Alex laughs bridge
who you will know from my vlogs
that's my gym buddy when I was back in
Bristol he lent this to me and basically
just said you've got to read this this
this is really good and he was
completely correct so this book isn't by
Nikesh Shukla it's curated by him it's
collated by him each chapter is a
different essay written by a different
author of color living in the UK and the
basic theme is what it's like to be not
white in the UK but the actual subject
matter varies all over the place talking
about feminism talking about family
history talking about religion talking
about
SOTA sociology and you know it's but
it's a huge broad cross-section it's
like a um a strata being laid down of
all of these personal experiences all of
these stories giving a real
you know cross-section this moment in
time what it is like to see the world
through someone completely different
eyes because I grew up in bath I grew up
in a place that was overwhelmingly white
I think at the last census it was like
96 percent white so growing up I never
really had the opportunity to understand
what it would be like to not be white
and you know when you hear as a kid you
know about racism you think it's only
going to be the dog barking stringing
them up from trees kind of racism it's
not going to be the pervasive everyday
subtle racism to a white person but
reading this series of essays from all
these authors makes it clear that you
know just because it's not that overt
really in your face even white people go
oh wow that's a bit too much kind of
racism it is still there and we are not
in a society that has even close to to
you know overcoming racism I mean we
think in the UK I think that you know we
basically we haven't more of a handle on
it than Americans do we just because of
the of the way our media works we were
exposed to the massive fractures in
American society along fault lines of
race we don't so much hear it in the UK
and so we're kind of implied to think
well over you know job done but past
that but of course we're not there's a
huge amount of work to do and for me as
someone who I don't honestly give it
what color your skin is or where you're
from I judge you by what you do as a
person so I consider myself to be an
ally in the struggle against bigotry
against racism but in order for me to
help in order for me to understand what
I can do I first need to understand the
problems and that was where this book
really shone through it really really
opened my eyes and you know I'd like to
think of myself as a relatively
well-rounded educated person so much of
this book was new to me so many new
ideas so many times I had to close the
book after reading an essay and really
think about why I read if you live in
the UK and you're white I really can't
recommend this book enough I think it is
eye-opening I think it is
absolutely necessary and I'm honestly so
glad that Alex recommended it to me I
feel like I finished this book a much
better rounded more educated person than
I was when I started so there you go
that's the lit it's literally the
strongest recommendation I can ever give
you you should read this book then just
three more books but I'm gonna do two of
them at once legion by Dan Abnett and
the wall master by Dan Abnett which I
also left at my parents house so there
you go just like in my previous video I
read a couple of books from the black
library the publishing window Games
Workshop these are for one hundred forty
thousand books which I adore I
absolutely love them I can blast through
them in a couple of days and it just
kinda like resets my my geekiness inside
so I realized the most if you're
watching this video I'm gonna be
interested but for what it's worth
Legion might be my favorites Horus
heresy novel Dan applet is just amazing
and you know it is it does get
ridiculous Legion it's like levels of
secrecy on secrecy and nobody trusting
each other which is of course what the
Alpha Legion does but you know it does
get a bit ridiculous and the wall master
is definitely out though of my favorite
Gaunt's ghost novels very little action
compared to the previous books this is
mostly just about character interactions
which just oh he's such a so good these
books are so well written if they're by
Dan after that he's definitely having
shoulders in my opinion above other
black library authors fight me in the
comments but if you're not reading gone
sky sonia 40k fan sort your life out and
get on it so you can read wall master
because the final book in the series is
gonna be coming very soon and dan abner
if I'm not gonna I'm not gonna say
spoilers here but if you've done what I
think you've done with with the knife
I'm coming for you you're not gonna do
what you did with Bragg and then lastly
returning to normal service it's a book
about memes it's this channel what you
expect the last book is memes in digital
culture by Lee Moore Schiffman and yes
this is a real a real book is published
by MIT about the study of internet memes
I literally just opened it to a random
page and there you go this is the kind
of thing we're dealing with here now
this book was a weird read I kind of
brought it for a laugh and I thought
open up
let's see what the academics have to say
about this oh because it was really
dense no it wasn't really dense um it's
just
I assume that unlike most people in that
when I look at memes I don't do so in
Abe
I don't critique memes I didn't think
about it with an academic mindset and so
when you know Lal cats is presented in a
book and it's done so in academic
language and it's done so with a kind of
a lens of analysis there's this weird
kind of disconnect where this I didn't
sign up for this I signed up for funny
pictures of cats and I think in the way
that the book is written you know
obviously it's an academic book it's
written by an academic the fact that
you're kind of pairing the subject
matter and the language means that
somebody came in just for the me who's
is gonna be disappointed but also I
don't think this the language is
actually academic enough really it feels
like kind of a halfway house where no
matter if you come into it for the memes
or for the academics I think you're
gonna walk away disappointed with how
this was written that being said it does
have some very interesting analysis in
it um it sort of talks about what
distinguishing between what makes a meme
and what makes you know something a
viral and you know and in fact the
identifed man identifies several
attributes of things which tend to go
viral by analysis of YouTube which you
know very interesting and certainly to a
creator like me potentially valuable if
you are a digital creator like a
youtuber you could do worse than reading
this but at the same time this it feels
really dated you know this was published
to me we would talk about the prints
earlier this one was published in 2014
and four years on the Internet is a long
time so when talking about rage comics
and lull cats obviously took the meme
economy these days these are basically
obsolete and that's actually an
interesting point about this book is
that obsolescence doesn't appear at all
it kind of assumes that when something
has become a meme it remains a meme
forever
and yes of course that is true you know
and that's a see another thing what
constitutes a meme very good definition
in here but a key part of a meme is how
alive it is who is sharing out how many
people are sharing who's remix seeing
this content
and it's not something this book talks
about to one I don't know if that's just
because by 2014 the internet wasn't old
enough for you know their lifecycles of
memes and virality to become a parent I
think it it had by then from memory and
I feel like the temporal aspect of this
book is really missing by the end of it
I was just sort of thinking this was
very flawed this felt like a missed
opportunity and you know Schiffman if
you end up watching this you might
because of the nature of what you've
been writing about I think that this was
worthwhile read and I think it was worth
writing it for some of the theoretical
stuff you've been talking about the
definition of memes and the things to me
the reasons for things going viral very
big thumbs up for me on that but I
didn't feel like this needed more pages
it needed more thought and it needed to
talk about other aspects of you know
what we jokingly called the meme economy
but if we're talking about memes in an
academic sense at all I feel like meme
economics is worth talking about as a
matter of fact memes in digital culture
would do very well I think in the format
of the book I'm currently reading which
I'm only reading one for the time being
which is the master algorithm by Pedro
Domingo's which is a very breezy I'm
only a chapter in but you can tell this
book is written it's rather dense
there's a lot of stuff going on here a
lot of technical information but it is
written in a very breezy non academic
way but those clearly thought very
deeply about the subject and it's what
300 pages long there's enough space in
here and based on what I've read so far
I think that space is being used well
there's nothing here to give a very good
overview of the subject this
incidentally is about machine learning
and you know the different ways in which
it's done I haven't read much of the
book I don't know yet but I feel like
there's an opportunity for these two
books to have some kind of unholy child
and you know to make the book about meme
economics and about about internet memes
and I think that is something that's
worthwhile doing maybe someone's already
writing it at the moment so there you go
that's what I've been reading over the
past couple of months I also have what
I'm going to be reading soon I have the
book of dust by Philip Pullman which is
the prequel to Northern Lights and His
Dark Materials which is one of my
favorite trilogies of all time so I'm
very excited to read that I was also
sent a bunch of books by the lovely
people at icon who just emailed me and
said she wants a book
no though yeah so these three are gonna
be devoured sometime soon I'm actually
trying to do a challenge on my Goodreads
I said I was gonna be 25 books this year
I'm slightly behind at the moment I've
caught up from a long way behind but I
reckon these are gonna be participating
relatively short fashion judging just
sort of flicking through how they've
been written I think these are gonna be
very nice holiday reading so thank you
very much icon I will be reviewing these
in the next video and while I will
almost certainly regret saying this if
you have any recommendations to add to
my teetering pile of to read on
Goodreads then please do put them down
in the comments if you've been reading
something interesting recently you can
also add me as a friend again I really
don't know how Goodreads works you can
add me as a friend and follow me I think
on Goodreads and you know maybe we could
resurrect the the book club a little
while ago on this channel there was a
book club where we said we were going to
read a book a month and then talk about
it that kind of fell apart after Dan and
I my ex housemate we're gonna read a
brief history of time and then one of us
didn't but if there's enough demand I
know some people have asked for it but
there's a lot demand we could resurrect
that Goodreads group and resurrect the
book club um you know I think that's a
worthwhile use of this channel it's I'm
clearly reading plenty anyway so it's
not exactly much extra work for me so if
that sounds interesting then comment
with that along with your book
recommendations along with fighting me
if you think the Dan Abner isn't the
best author in the black library like a
muggle and thank you for watching this
rambling incoherent all over the place
book review video I'll do one again in a
couple of months thanks for watching see
you in the next one
[Music]